how long does gorilla tactics need to
you know be implemented before that
actually is conventional warfare like at
this at this point there's no
standing armies lining up across the
battlefield from each other anymore
right like isn't all unconventional
warfare today are all warfare today
technically unconventional
uh i mean yeah uh the warfare that i
thought in is very unconventional
because you know there's no declared two
sides of the army right you're not
not you know you're in this uniform in
this uniform this is the battlefield no
it's the battlefield is in the united
states the battlefields in yemen sana in
iraq afghanistan all these different
areas the battlefield for for me was
the secret wars you know so
and that's what i mean so when when
vietnam fell to that
um
you know they started raising
unconventional warfare they knew look
guys warfare is expensive we know that
right after afghanistan iraq warfare is
expensive so the chinese if you study
their their tactics under sanju
warfare is expensive they'll never
employ soldiers
to put a footprint there for too long
americans do and that's our mistake
right so we employ americans overseas
we're funding americans to fight these
wars right overseas how expensive is it
to to keep americans overseas how
expensive is the ford ammunition
supplies
uh weapons you know the uh the assets
like the drones potentially
intentionally so though i mean the
industrial military complex has made a
lot of people mega wealthy and they've
never had to step foot outside of d.c
so when the country failed to uh to
communism um
eventually it failed to communism
and americans pulled out because it was
expensive war it was an unpopular war it
was an unpopular war because up until
then
the the media censored everything
right so do you think about war two
right think about war two war one the
philippines all these different wars you
watch that the media censors everything
it was until the vietnam war was when
they allow reporters to come in and
unfortunately guys hey look when you see
women and children dying in warfare and
you see to true realities of war it's
ugly and it smells and it stinks
so when america is getting a snapshot of
i don't know
a
american killing a civilian is it
because i've been in countries where
rebels will come in and wipe out a whole
village
and have an eight-year-old is he
now
a militant or is he still a child
because he just killed his parents
you see it's a different world what's
what i'm saying to you so
you know when vietnam failed to that and
the americans they could not sustain
this
unpopular very expensive war that's
unconventional they're not used in fact
the green berets and special forces were
developed to combat
you know this insurgency
you know that's where it came from
so when that country fell to at ho chi
minh was able to establish a more
communist regime and his main concern
once he took over the country south
vietnam was to make sure that our
leaders would never rise up to power
again like afghanistan
think about like anybody who hold
position to power
they're murdered
they're killed right so the same with
the vietnamese if anybody holds position
power like my uncles had they were
officers they were drugged out to the
camps and tortured
you know we were oppressed simply for
what opposing ideas ideas that they did
not agree with ideas that contradicted
what they believed in well like you know
sarajevo bosnia you know people
different ideologies they will wipe out
a whole existence because you don't
believe what they believe yeah and
dissension it you know disagreement seen
as dissension it's not seen as civil
discourse one of the great things about
the way our country was founded it was
founded on civil discourse let's have
this disagreement let's have the two
houses argue it out and then let's have
it you know then let's you know have a
law as opposed to the top-down you know
decree mandate from the king right so
but i i want to say this because when i
came over to america right you know
because i lived like i lived in a
refugee camp for a year and a half guys
you know in indonesia and it was a grass
hut in the middle of the jungle you have
to survive you have to live off the land
they don't give you
anything hipsters do that for vacation
now too they do they get
spiritual it's very spiritual because
you know what's really weird is that you
we are all successful men we we we value
certain things but i'll tell you man
when i went into these third world
countries in these villages where there
was
nothing
they were happy
so what are we doing wrong
we're looking at the externals to be
happy
you know it goes underneath samurai
teachings it goes underneath the print
but we look for the externals to make
ourselves happy these days right
so i think that's what's wrong with
america and what's wrong with a modern
day society if you go to these thorough
countries they are happy because they're
around their families and around their
friends so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you